about mip star equal to re one of the
biggest breakthroughs and complexity in
the last few years
um thanks prasad so you can you can hear
me uh good morning
i'll um echo elite's words and saying
that
first of all it's a pleasure and an
honor to be uh here speaking at the at
the celebration and i also very much
want to thank the the simons institute
for
uh its continued support of tcs and
quantum computing in particular
uh that's had a pretty big importance in
my uh in my research career so i
participated right after i entered my
phd i participated in one of the
first programs here in quantum
hamiltonian complexity actually was the
first program in the that was in calvin
hall
and some of the things that i'm going to
talk about were born during that program
so i pointed out in a particular place
in in the talk and we're having right
now of course uh
another quantum reunion over over the
summer so um
it's really been a great institute to uh
to have around
so the results that i'm going to talk
about is a result in quantum complexity
theory it's it's summarized in the
equality that gives the title to the
talk
this is an equality between two
complexity classes uh that i'll define a
little bit uh later in the talk um
this equality is uh is interesting from
a complexity theoretic point of view
but some of its importance is also due
to the um impact and applications that
it's had to questions in the in the
foundations of
of quantum mechanics and also in in pure
mathematics um so i'm going to try to
give you all the different
perspectives on the results just
introduce it and motivate it
um and and i'll start with the the
physical angle because that's uh that's
often more uh more fun
so in order to do that i have to go back
uh
quite a bit in the past to the 1930s
so in the 1930s
you know lots of stuff was going on so
how mickey mouse made this first
operation
uh some other less fun things you know
stock stock market crash happened um
okay the more relevant to the talk is is
this particular headline which is
actually if you take the time to read it
quite a remarkable riff on the
um so this is new york times 1935 so of
course they're referring to the einstein
povolsky rosen
thought experiment
which if you know about it you can
understand what what they're saying if
you don't i'm not i'm not sure
uh so okay so i'm not going to go into
the details of that uh of that uh
thought experiment um instead i want to
give you uh with the benefit of
hindsight on just
one angle on it which is which is
relevant for the talk um
so a particular aspect of quantum
mechanics that uh
puzzle dpr and and many uh
at the time is uh what we refer to what
is the non-locality of quantum mechanics
so to explain that i have to describe um
a thought experiment so the thought
experiment is as follows you imagine
that you have two physical systems a and
b
each of them receives um inputs taken
from a certain range of inputs and they
produce uh
outputs also in a certain range so think
of these as just um numbers
so we think of these physical systems as
being isolated so one of them is on
earth and the other is on moon on the
moon
and the question is what's the right way
to model mathematically
uh the kind of situations that you can
observe in this scenario
so if you model this classically the
first the most natural um way to do it
is to say well
you know you have the a system the b
system um these are separated so let's
just have a distribution uh that models
what happens at a so this is
distribution on outcomes given the the
inputs and the distribution what models
that
that model is what happens at b
and the global distribution is is a
product distribution between these two
because there's no interaction between
these two systems
you could say oh but um you know the
earth and the moon there's the big bang
they were they were created together at
some point so there can be some
correlation that has been injected into
these systems along in the past and you
can model that correlation using what's
what's sometimes referred to as a as a
local hidden variable so this is just a
distribution um on random variables
lambda you sampled some lambda in in the
past and there's a copy of it that's
sitting on the earth and a copy of it
that's saying on the moon
and so these distributions these local
distributions can also depend on on on
laptop okay so you'd say
uh this is a reasonable model for the
class of distributions that can be
generated uh in in my thought experiment
okay they must have this form
and you can plot them um so it's it's
it's kind of important for the talk to
understand what the picture on the left
uh is
so each point in this picture is a
vector
of probabilities okay it's all the
probabilities um they're all
probabilities that are used to model
certain experiments so
if x and y are both zero what's the
probability that a and b are both zero
uh that they're both one that they're
zero and one etc so each of these
probabilities is an entry in the vector
and this vector i represent using a
single point and then i can draw a
polytope which is the class of all
distributions that can be generated
using this uh using this experiment
it's a polytope and the extreme points
are products deterministic product
distributions and then when i introduced
this lambda um in terms of the picture
this amounted to taking the convex hub
of the of the extreme points right
so that's if you model the experiment
classically now if you model it using
quantum mechanics
the main difference is that this
kind of correlation that comes from the
past between the two systems you can you
can say that um
there's some physical system like think
of a pair of photons or something like
this that was created in the past in a
certain physical state and then one of
the photons just stayed on earth and the
other was just you know in in in the
moon
and so when you do the experiment uh
these outcomes a and b that are
generated on the earth and on moon these
this can be correlated with the state of
the photons okay maybe some measurement
happens on the photon and the a is this
contains some information about that
photon but of course a contains only
information about the photon that's on
earth and b about the photon that's
that's on the one
and now you ask a physicist okay well
what's the class of distributions that
can be generated in this experiment and
they'll write for you the the bone rule
um so it's it's not important to
understand this formula right now
psi is a vector it's the the state uh
vector that that represents the state of
my photons and a and b are measurements
that are performed on the earth
what is important is just that if you
plot it you get a bigger set
um and that that's part of of course the
epr thought experiment is much more
subtle than that but it is part of what
what was confusing is that your
intuition really uh tells you that the
correct class of this i don't
i guess i could move the class of
distributions is this class of
distributions okay you have some local
operation at ali's local operation that
b you take the convex hull it's the most
natural thing in the world
and now you have a new theory of physics
and it says well um
there's uh a bigger set of correlations
that can be observed so you try to
understand well okay what does that mean
like what what kind of things about the
world do i have to revisit in order to
accommodate uh this this new picture and
that's what epr we're doing
um
okay so so there's experiments that are
performed to to demonstrate this this is
one of the first experiments in the 80s
this is one uh more recent in 2012 in uh
in delft and even more recently um you
can do these experiments using
satellites that beam the pair of photons
to different cities in china for example
and then measurements are performed and
you check the statistics and you do all
the statistics you compute all the
probabilities you plot it on the figure
and you see it's outside of the
classical set okay so you just have to
accept this
all right so
experiments they kind of demonstrates uh
what is possible so you can think of
them as as lower bounds
but we might also be interested in in
upper bounds
on what is achievable um
and that's what
mathematicians
do so the these pictures in terms of
correlations uh they were first
introduced by
a uh israeli mathematical physicist boy
silson and he he drew all these sets um
so he drew the classical set that i had
that i gave you before and he drew the
quantum set um and as he was thinking
through them he realized that in fact
and this was in the 1980s so einstein
bore these people were you know gone
unfortunately
still it wasn't quite decided what was
the proper way to model what can be
achieved in quantum mechanics okay so
there's different mathematical ways to
do it one of them i gave you already um
and this way of doing it um it it
consists in saying that um the way you
should model things that the earth is a
particular system and to that system we
associate the hilbert space quantum
mechanics is based on hybrid spaces we
have a hypnose space for the earth
hilbert space for moon and then how do
you represent the fact that these are
isolated uh you take the tensor product
of the hilbert spaces it's this tensor
product that uh that is that is here and
the state vector lies in the tensorboard
spaces okay so if that's if that's the
map that you accept then you get this
set um but since observed that there's a
slightly more general definition you
could give
uh it's it's inspired by our
relativistic quantum mechanics um you
could forget about this idea that there
has to be different hilbert spaces for
different space-time regions because
what what does that mean like each
system has a different space is very
confusing so there's just a single table
space for the whole universe
and the way you represent special
isolation is using commutation so you
say okay whatever operation is performed
on the earth whatever operation is
performed on the moon because they're
isolated the order in which i perform
these operations shouldn't matter but
that's the only constraint that i'm
placing
and so if you do that you get a set that
a priori could be different it's it's
bigger because the the tensor product is
is it implies commutation uh but but
vice versa is not clear
um i i actually also thought that the
two definitions are equal and if you
know a little bit of math um you can
show without too much work that if
everything is finite dimensional these
definitions are equal and so you could
say you know that's fine right they're
equal
later on people realize that
actually there could be a difference
between these sets and so whether there
is a difference or not this became known
as stillson's problem okay so this
problem is just you have these two
possible mathematical ways of modeling
locality in quantum mechanics do they
give rise to the same distributions or
do they not
so that question was posed in the 90s i
think um
and um
so the question is whether there's a
point there um and you can say okay like
fine that's the question in the
foundations where you just told me that
if everything is finite dimensional it
it doesn't matter and we're computer
scientists everything is finitely
dimensional so let's just move on right
and then basically that's what happened
um the question was posed they didn't
didn't really matter too much and people
moved on um
until
in the 90s there was a very surprising
connection that was established between
this problem and some problems that had
been opened uh in in the theory of
operator algebra so in mathematics for a
couple uh
or uh for for
four decades
um and this connection gave much
suddenly gave more importance to
substance problems so i'm
going to do it like a tiny bit of
mathematics now to explain the
mathematical angle
for that i have to go back to the 1930s
the second time there'll be a third time
a little bit later
so in the 1930s um people were still
developing the math for quantum
mechanics so there was uh schroedinger's
wave formulation there was heisenberg's
matrix mechanics and the matrix
mechanics was picked up by uh by von
neumann who's a mathematician and he
started developing all the math required
uh to make the physicists um you know
scribbles um
no offense meant
rigorous um and so he did this it took
quite a while so um together with murray
he he developed the theory of what are
known now known uh
as vondeman algebras and he pushed it
much further than what's required for
the uh for the physics
so they started uh you know
investigating different types of
fundamental algebras um and classifying
these these volume and algebras
now alan collins is is another
mathematician who in the in the 1970s so
you know 40 years later they were still
hard working on this classification work
in fact khan's gone got the the fields
medal for his work on classifying von
neumann algebras
and in one of these papers
one of his major papers he made a
comment about you know
it looked like some algebra had some
finite dimensional model and he said oh
it should be the case that every kind of
such algebra has a finite dimensional
approximation he wasn't sure about it
and he moved on
um but that that particular comment um
later became known as khan's embedding
problems so i i can't define it
precisely
um
it's a problem that that gained
prominence due to the work of other
mathematicians that connected it to more
conjectures in operative algebras easter
algebras then it went outside of that
for example to free probability or
group theory so so let me give just to
give you a flavor of what this
conjecture is about i'll state
a slightly weaker conjecture but it's
easier to formulate it's a conjecture in
group theory so it's a question whether
every countable group is is hyperlinear
um so let's first think about finite
groups uh so everyone knows that finite
groups have finite dimensional
representations so if you have any
finite group you can realize it
as operations on matrices okay there's a
bunch of matrices that are going to
multiply exactly like you ask them to
multiply into groups that's for finite
groups now what about infinite groups
infinite groups don't necessarily have
finite dimensional representations
uh what about approximate finite
dimensional representations so that's
the question this is a conjecture it's
an open it's an open problem
the problem is whether every countable
group so just the number of elements in
the group is countable is hyperlinear
and it's hyperlinear if every finite
subset of the group can be arbitrarily
well approximated by finite dimensional
matrices but the dimension of the
matrices can grow with the quality of
the approximation and with the size of
the subset of the group that you're
trying to approximate okay so constant
welding problem has a very similar
flavor but it's about algebras and not
uh they're not groups
okay so around 2011 2012
um
due to the work of some mathematicians
so mathematical physicists showed that
this this constant bending problem which
was open since 1976 so for 50 years
already this was equivalent to citizen's
problem uh it's kind of a surprising
equivalence because tilton's problem is
a problem about the equality between two
convex sets there's no algebra that's
obviously visible uh there con's
embedding problem has no tensor progress
it's just about a single algebra so this
is a very surprising connection and it
it suddenly you know gave um
made people interested in silson's
problem again because it kind of gives
you a new angle on some old uh
mathematical conjectures
okay so that's what we're going to try
to do now uh we're interested in
tilson's problem we're going to try to
resolve it um
so a priori it's a pretty simple problem
um it's really a problem between the
quality of two convex sets uh which are
the nicest kind of sets that that uh
that you might want to consider
and also i want to emphasize that these
sets are not like infinite dimensional
or anything this is all in finite
dimensions so i can draw my sets in a
you know in a cube and this cube lives
in a space that has dimension you know
the number of inputs and outputs that i
have for my thought experiment n is the
number of inputs k is the number of
outputs this question is interesting
when n and k are both equal to five okay
so you don't need to think of very uh
very very very large pictures
okay so you have two convex sets uh you
want to separate them how do you do it
uh you find a linear function that
separates them okay so i can draw a
linear function like this
and given the linear function i can ask
for what's the maximum that the linear
function takes over any of the three
convex sets that's in the picture
i can give a name to this maximum so
this omega is the maximum over dollar
the first quantum set the one that's
modeled using tensor product this is the
maximum over the uh the second one the
one that's measured using commuting
operations and if we could just find one
linear function such that we can show
that these two optimum are distinct we'd
be done um
so then you say okay well you know why
don't you do this right computing
optimum of linear functions over convex
sets that's that's easy um so just like
you know discretize your space search
over all linear functionals compute
these optimums and just find it if it
exists
the problem is that computing optimums
of um linear functions over convex sets
is easy
if okay if this convex set is is
minimally reasonable in particular if
you have a membership oracle okay if you
have a way to test given a point is it
in the complex site and that's that's
you know usually the case this is why we
say that linear optimization over convex
sets is easy but it's not the case for
these sets okay because you saw the
definition and it involves these tests
or products in these separate spaces and
not priority i don't have um a way given
a point to test whether it's in the set
or not um so i don't know how to
optimize these these linear functions
so we need to find other ways to
construct interesting linear functions
and say things about them
and um that's what we're going to do for
the remainder of the talk and the way
we'll do it is by drawing
kind of a surprising connection with a
third
area which is which is complexity theory
and in particular the theory of
interactive books
uh so let me explain this now i have to
go back again to the 1930s um actually
it's not true i don't have to go back to
the 1930s but but still just for the
sake of it um okay so we're all familiar
with uh with that theory i don't need to
explain it um in fact hearing is going
to show up again right at the end of the
talk
but but for now let me put this aside um
and tell you about interactive proofs
uh so so let's start from the basics say
the complexity class np so an np of
course stands for non-deterministic
polynomial time
but shortly after the class was was
introduced um i think people realized
that there's a different way to think
about it that that's proven particularly
insightful
so it's thinking about np as the class
of problems that have efficiently
verifiable proofs okay so you
um
a problem in this class should be such
that there's a deterministic polynomial
time procedure this is this v there and
it gets uh instance of the problem it's
trying to decide if this instance is a
yes or no instance
in order to do that it can run in
polynomial time
but it can also receive help in the form
of a proof
and so it should be the case that inputs
that are in the language have valid
proofs that are accepted and inputs that
are not in the language
do not have valid proofs that that's an
equivalent definition of the class
np so this is the 70s uh that np
completeness theory was was developed
now um jumping to the eight the eighties
another particularly insightful
observation was made and
this observation came from two different
angles but one of them is uh
cryptography where in cryptography these
proofs are you know actual things that
you're doing like think about proving
your identity to an atm or something
you're doing this okay so it's not like
some theoretical non-deterministic
algorithm
um and studying a certain property that
such proofs can have the zero knowledge
property
um
researchers including shafi shafi um
started studying what happened if you
brought in the class a little bit and
you allow not just deterministic
verification but you allow two extra
things one of them is interaction with
the proof which we now model as a
proverb so it's a machine that you can
ask questions to and you also allow
randomized verification so you're
allowed to make errors with uh with a
small probability
uh this this leads to a new complexity
class ip and and further work uh showed
that ip seems to be bigger than p space
so it seems to there'd be an expressive
gain in
uh verification power that's that's
obtained by adding uh randomness in
interaction so you get you get you get p
space
okay it is now 90s uh one last
conceptual leap
this one again motivated by by
cryptography and again studying uh zero
knowledge you can ask if it makes a
difference if the verification procedure
is allowed to ask uh questions interact
with two provers instead of one
uh so you you know it's this is not
obvious that there's any gain to this at
first because uh you know what's the
point of having two proofs you just you
know put them together and it's just one
proof but if you remember that this
procedure is interactive uh then then
you might see the advantage it's a bit
like
interrogating suspects and you put them
in different rooms this allows you to
cross check their answers and you gain a
little bit of verification power so
there's maybe fewer chances
that someone
is able to convince you of a false
statement
and indeed this is the case and um
so this the associated complexity class
is called mip uh bye bye for no longer
in 91 showed that it's equal to nx
okay so it's important here there's been
an exponential gain
in the complexity of problems that you
can verify as you moved from
static deterministic verification to
interactive randomized verification with
two provers okay there's three more
ingredients you had an exponential gain
in power and offshoots of this result
include the pcp theorem that eric
told us a lot about so even though this
pcb theorem
when you state it has nothing to do with
interactive proofs uh this this is this
is where it came this is where it came
from
okay that's the classical theory of
quantum of interactive proofs uh and our
quantum computation comes along and it
just opens up like a whole new set of
questions you can ask oh well what if
the proof is quantum what if the
interaction involves quantum
communication
how does that change the complexity
classes and these are things that have
been studied extensively and i'm not
going to do the whole theory there i
just want to focus on one particular
modification that's been particularly
useful and productive so
it starts off with a
multi-prover i'll just focus on the case
where there's two provers here uh
interactive proofs and the only change
you make
is the same change that you made that i
made in the thought experiment i
described earlier you say well what if
we think of this as something that's
actually physically uh embodied that is
happening these two proverbs are there
one is on earth was it on the moon well
you know what if they have photons
between them there's no way i can
present prevent them from from sharing
photons
how does that affect uh the the model um
that's a question that was raised um 20
years ago by cleveland and collaborators
they coined the the name for the class
mip star so star just refers to the fact
that there's entanglement between the
provers and they asked what's the
expressive power
of that class
and it's interesting to think through
this because there's really two
different phenomena that could be taking
place
the first one is that what i just did is
i broadened the range of strategies that
are accessible to the approvers okay
before they were two prisoners let's say
they were isolated in different rooms
and they had to perform local operations
in order to determine their answers now
i give them a little bit more i give
them photons okay so i give them access
to a slightly broader class of
strategies uh using these strategies
they might be able to cheat uh in in
situations where they weren't able to
cheat before if they cheat they defeat
the soundness of my proof system and the
verification power of the verifier could
be reduced maybe if these correlations
are so strong i completely lose any
advantage there and two provers are no
better than just one and in this case
this complexity class mip start would
collapse to the single prover class ip
to p space that's something that could
happen
on the other hand um you know your
verification procedure knows this um
so maybe you can use it to your
advantage if the approvals are more
powerful in a way they have different
correlations maybe we can develop new
tests um that would affect the
completeness of my proof system and i'd
be able to verify things that i wasn't
able to verify uh before okay so this is
also something like a little bit more
strange but it could be happening you
know
i want to give you a concrete example of
the kind of tests or games that you play
in this
setting this is a this is a very simple
one
called the odd cycle game um so in the
odd cycle game you imagine in your head
the odd cycle so this one has five
vertices
and what you do in the game is that you
try to check that um the odd cycle is is
too colorable
okay so of course because it's it's odd
it's not too colorable but if you try to
check it here's one way you might do it
you might pick a pair of vertices so the
first vertex i chose the vertex i and i
ask one of the provers for the color of
that vertex and they'll tell me it's
either green or blue
and then i choose for the other prover
either the same vertex and then i'll
make sure they give me the same answer
just to check that they're consistent or
a neighboring vertex and then i check
that they give me different uh answers
okay and it's important that these two
proverbs they only see which vertex
they're asked about not what the other
person was asked about so they don't
really have a good way
to coordinate
um and so it's not hard to see that if i
was playing this game with an even uh
cycle the proofers could fix uh a two
coloring of the even cycle and they
could succeed in the game for d1 but if
the cycle is odd and has n vertices you
can compute the maximum success
probability and it's it's that that
number basically there must be an error
somewhere right either they give
different answers for this different
colors for the same vertex or there's an
edge that's not too colored
and now you can ask the question what if
i look at quantum strategies in this
game um does it change the success
probability and and the point is that it
does so you can do the computation and
the success priority gets gets a little
bit higher so i'm showing you this
example just to show that uh to argue
that
the difference between these two sets of
strategies doesn't only happen for like
weird things that you don't care about
okay this is a very natural game we care
about it and there is a difference
between quantum and classical strategies
for it um
all right
so
i want just to you know i'll get back to
my original question citizens problem a
little bit later but i still so that you
know where we're going i want to make
the connection now so these games such
as the odd cycle game you can think of
them as linear functions it's really
just the same thing so here i'm drawing
again the picture in this picture
earlier i said there each point on this
picture is a probability vector
so each point is a strategy okay it's a
it's each point represents a class of
distributions that um my provers or my
players could be generating uh in a
certain game and here i have the kind of
classical distributions so context
combinations of product this is the
first quantum one and i didn't draw uh
the second one in one
and what the game does is it assigns a
score to any possible strategy and in
fact and and and this function from
strategy to score
is a linear function so the odd cycle
you can represent it as a linear
function like this
and the fact that there was a larger
success probability
for quantum strategies
this is represented pictorially by the
fact that there's a gap here between the
two different optima of this linear
function on the classical set and and
and and and on the quantum set right
um it's a linear function because how do
you compute the score in the game you
sum over all possible questions and
answers
of the probability of giving these
answers and questions that's an entry in
my vector times one or zero with whether
this answer is is valid or not okay so
you're just summing a subset
of the probabilities and that that's a
linear function
not all linear functions are of this
form but games give us a large class of
linear functions to think about and try
to find separations between not these
two sets i just did that but the blue
one and the purple one that that we had
earlier
okay so let's go back to the theory of
interactive tools i have to develop a
little bit uh a little bit more so we
have this question about the power of
quantum interactive proofs uh that that
question was was opened in 2004 when the
class was uh was developed and and so so
people started you know trying to work
on it so one of the first results is a
result that i had at the end of my phd
with ito
um and what we showed is that this
potential collapse that i described
earlier where it could be that uh these
quantum strategies are used to defeat
your proof system this doesn't
happen in general in fact we showed that
it doesn't happen for a specific proof
system but that's the important one it's
the proof system that was used in the
babaya dial paper showing that mip is
equal to nx now the main ingredient in
that proof system is something called
multilinearity test it's not important
that i get into that
and we showed that for that particular
game
there's not a big gap between the
classical and quantum values there could
be a gap but it's not that big enough to
defeat the proof system and so it showed
this inclusion
and so i was there this was the end of
my phd i was pretty happy with it and i
thought you know we're probably pretty
much done now
a little bit i didn't quite know how to
prove a matching upper bound so to show
equality but i thought it's going to
happen pretty soon
um okay but i didn't manage um and then
i went to the assignments um
and i co-organized one of the workshops
there and in the workshop we had a ramp
session and uh umesh vazirani was there
and also dorit runoff and they kind of
like pumped me up at the start of the
ramp session saying look you know like
uh is nx really the right answer these
are quantum proof systems so why don't
you put qmax in there
qma is just the quantum analog of np
where you have a quantum proof um and i
thought this is kind of weird because
still
these questions and answers are
classical so why would you have a
quantum quantum proof in there okay but
i posed it as an open question
and someone in the audience had an idea
this is joe fitzsimmons and we worked
out the idea and then i had later worked
with uh anand natarayana mata ryan sorry
anand
i'm not stating what these results are
because it doesn't matter the point is
that they kind of answered
the question
the only thing that i want to say about
them that that's a little bit relevant
is that in order to show these results
you had to do a little bit more than
take a classical test and show that it's
sound against quantum proofers you
really had to do
what i said earlier invent a new proof
system try to say okay now we're going
to go beyond what's possible classically
so you have to we have to come up with a
test that cannot be passed if you do not
have entitlement so it's really a test
for entanglement and this is what we
developed and that test for entanglement
is based on a very famous classical test
called the bloom louis rubenfeld
linearity test
so the linearity test is some procedure
you can execute in order to verify that
the provers
determine their answers according to a
linear function a linear function from
the additive group z2 to the n to the
multiplicative group plus minus one
with the test that we developed uh it
involves verifying that the provers
answer according to like a quantum
linear function if you want so now it's
a representation
uh linear functions are just
representations but it's z2 is is a
billion group so representations are are
just characters they're just one
dimensional
p2 is is the quantum analog of of z2
it's it's the the group that's generated
by by a qubit if you want so you can
take these two matrices these are famous
matrices and quantum information they're
called the poly matrices
uh what's special about them is that
they square to identity uh so just like
a bit you know plus minus one square to
identity or quantum analog of a bit but
they don't commute okay bits commute
qubits don't commute so they generate a
group which is a non-billion group and
it's this group p2
this group has a unique non-trivial
representation it's the one that's
generated by these by these matrices and
the quantum linearity test tests that
strategies act according to these uh
these matrices
this is this is this is not uh crucial
but i want to i want to show you in the
picture what's going on because there is
something interesting so these are my
three sets and now let's think about the
linearity test the classical linearity
test as a
as a linear function right i told you
any game or any test is a linear
function so what kind of linear function
is it
so it's that kind okay
first of all it doesn't point to a
particular vertex because there's many
possible strategies that can succeed any
linear strategy or any complex
combination of strategies so what it
points at is to a facet
and it's a facet whose extreme points
are um essentially uh linear linear uh
linear functions
and earlier when we did this quantum
soundless work we showed that this is
not a facet that's particularly
interesting quantumly uh you can play
the same test with quantum improvers and
you get the same class of optimal
strategies
okay so it's all the three sets they
kind of match here
in contrast this quantum linearity test
it's a different kind of linear function
it points like more than this way first
of all there's a difference between
classical and quantum
classical strategies cannot succeed uh
in that test it requires entanglement
and second um there's a unique quantum
optimum there's not a whole family of
them there's really a unique quantum
strategy that that succeeds in the in
the test
that'll be relevant you know
in in a second
all right so um
at this point you know i told you about
many different things uh but it's it's
good we have all the ingredients that
are needed in order to make uh progress
on on this question of understanding the
power of quantum interactive proofs and
then circling back to tillerson's
problem
uh so i want to give you just like one
you know
kind of conceptual bit of information um
about what's what's going to happen and
it's it's in this slide so this this
slide is kind of important
um
so i'll start with a classical question
and um this is kind of um
maybe the main lesson of the mip equals
nx result
is that computations so you could think
even of deterministic exponential time
computation you can also think of
non-deterministic exponential time
computations can be verified much more
efficiently than they need to than the
amount of time that they need to be
carried out okay and this requires a few
steps you can take your large
computation you can write down the whole
table of the computation you'll encode
that tableau in an error correcting code
you'll choose the error correcting code
wisely just as
it was talking about so that you can
build probabilistically checkable proof
out of it
and then you're able to check validity
of the entire computation by making just
a few random local checks to this uh
appropriately encoded proof okay so this
is an exponential savings in decision
time
um
by moving from just or
computation by moving from decision to
verification and allowing
random local checks okay
okay so now here's another question what
if we try to apply this idea of
exponential savings in in a computation
not starting with a deterministic or
non-deterministic computation but
starting directly with an interactive
proof which is the model that we've been
working uh on so what if we take now an
interactive proof like this this is just
a classical interactive proof but let's
think of it as an exponential time uh
verifier so this verifier runs in
exponential time and i don't want to do
that i want to verify the verifier okay
so could i do that
so there's two things that this verifier
does the first thing that it does is it
chooses questions
and the second thing that it does is
that it gets answers and it verifies
that
so the part about delegating the
verification of the answers
that can be done in fact for those of
you who know it's the idea behind proof
behind uh composition of pcps uh you can
reduce to the case where the
verification of answers procedure is
deterministic so it's just some
deterministic exponential time
computation and you can kind of delegate
that
the tricky part is the the questions
right and kind of like obviously there's
no way to delegate the sampling of
questions i mean i could tell these guys
to generate their own questions
but i have to verify they do it
correctly
and the problem is that there is no such
thing as a correct question all
questions are correct what's important
is how they're generated okay they need
to choose a randomness correctly if i
allow them to choose the random string
themselves then they choose a random
string that kind of like generates you
know just like some really easy question
the digits always get the same question
and it's just not going to work out
right so you don't even think about it
that's it it's done mit equals the next
there's no way to push it forward
except if you can use quantum mechanics
okay so
um it is i mean it's well known that
quantum mechanics is uh is is is a
probabilistic theory so the the
measurement rule the bourne rule says
that uh you you observe uh outcomes with
with probabilities they're not
necessarily deterministic a little bit
less well-known um you know maybe for
people who don't do this but but
actually very well known in quantum
information since the the birth of the
field in the 1980s 90s is that not only
is quantum mechanics uh random but it's
random in a way that can be verified um
and that that's the idea behind quantum
cryptography behind quantum key
distribution it's the idea that if you
have a quantum system that is supposed
to generate random bits according to a
certain distribution you can do some
tests on it and these are not quantum
tests they're just tests on the
distribution that's being generated to
make sure that this distribution is
really uniformly random distribution you
need that in order to do cryptography
you want to make sure that your keys are
uniformly random and uncorrelated with
you know whatever you need them to be
uncorrelated with
uh so it's known since even before that
time that there are some linear
functions here's an example of them it's
a famous one um the chsh linear
functions hsh are initials of the people
who who found it that is such that
there's a unique quantum optimum just
just like before
and this unique quantum optimum has the
property that you know the probabilities
if you list them and if you look just as
the marginal distribution
on
the a answers prover one's answers this
is a uniform distribution
so that's a linear function
and it has a unique optimum and the
unique optimum
the way to achieve it you have to
generate uniformly random bits these
uniformity and bits have to be
correlated in a very peculiar way with
the other party but if you look at just
one party
it's uniformly random
so you know there we are uh we have a
way to test that someone generates
uniformly random bits so why don't we
build on that
and uh delegate the question
distribution uh to the approvers by just
making sure that they actually used
exactly the right distribution
so that's a good idea and then it
there's a bit of work in order to make
it uh to implement it um two particular
uh
difficulties that you have is one uh you
need to do this in a very efficient way
okay so this chsh inequality is good but
in order to test one bit of randomness
it kind of requires you know one bit of
effort uh and in quantum crypto this is
what happens to generate n bits of key
you need to put in omega of n amount of
effort so you are testing the randomness
but you're not doing it efficiently um
so one of the things that we did is uh
build on the pcp literature uh in this
quantum linearity test that i described
before but do that for more advanced
tests multi-linearity test low degree
tests in order to get efficient tests uh
for randomness okay so you have
exponential savings between the amount
of randomness that you generate and the
amount of effort that's required in
terms of the length of the questions the
verification time in order to generate
this randomness
that that's one difficulty uh and the
other difficulty um that was tackled by
uh natarayan and wright
a couple years ago is that you know it's
not only about uniform distributions
what makes these two prover systems
special
is that the questions are correlated in
a very specific way you don't always
send the same uniformly random question
or independent uniformly running
questions it's a bit more subtle and so
you need to come up with tests that make
sure that each of the prover generates
the right distribution and it's
correlated in the right way with the
other person and that that you know
that's a bit delicate but um but they
did that
and once you've done that um they were
already able to show like one more step
one more exponential improvement uh
going from nx to n e that's like two
exponentials so you delegate
mip equals nx to
mip star and you get that inclusion and
once you've done it once you you know
okay well why don't we continue surely
there must be some parameter that blows
up okay maybe not the randomness maybe
not the question language some other
parameter blows up you can't do this
forever
um and so actually you can um it
requires a little bit more work but this
is this is what we did a couple years
ago
by iterating this argument and not only
iterating but taking a limit are we able
to show that the class are e so re is uh
larger than any deterministic or
non-deterministic bounded time class
uh it stands for recursively and
enumerable so it's all languages such
that there's an algorithmic procedure
that lists
valid instances but but there's no bound
in the amount of time
it's not hard to show that there's a
matching upper bound this was known for
a while we just we just didn't think
that it would be the correct upper bound
but it turns out that it is and so that
that gives the equality that that
the head that's titled for the talk is
surprising equality because on the right
hand side you have a model that involves
pointing on your time um polynomial time
verification
there's quantum sure but it's still
point real time verification on the left
hand side you have an absolutely huge
class in fact a complete problem for re
is is the halting problem that's an
undecidable problem
okay so some undecidable problems can be
verified in classical polynomial time if
you interact with a quantum system
and just to receive your complexity
theorists and you've thought about these
interactive proof classes it's it's it's
a surprising result so that that's the
complexity theoretic motivation for the
problem
uh but but i'll just wrap up by by
circling back to tilson's problem so now
i've been you know talking a lot about
complexity theory
um and my motivation was to design
interesting linear functionals
so let's go back uh to the sets and and
i let me tell you now why uh from this
complexity theoretical quality we've
actually managed to show that there's a
separation between the two sets it's a
tiny bit of a subtle and surprising
argument but let me go over it so these
are the two sets that tillerson was
interested in okay two sets of
two different ways that um
you can model correlations in quantum
mechanics and we're trying to show that
they're not equal so we're trying to
come up with a linear function
i'm actually not going to come up with
it explicitly although we can do it but
right now i'll just show you an
existence argument why there must exist
such a linear function
okay so one thing i could have said
earlier on but i didn't want you to
forget about it
is that if you're studying this like a
very natural question from a computer
scientist point of view is i told you it
might be hard to optimize this linear
function over these sets but what is
known um there's two things that are
known
one i already mentioned is like
experiments so
it is possible to approach uh the tensor
product value by below just by doing
exhaustive search so you just say okay
let me fix dimensions for everything
from my hibble spaces let me discretize
everything and let me increase
everything the dimension the accuracy
and i get better and better by
exhaustive search better and various
strategies and you can show that this
exhaustive search
converges by below two to one of the
values
now much more work
is showing that there is also a
refutation procedure
that approaches the other value from
above so for those of you who know this
is a non-commutative version of the sum
of squares hierarchy that you can apply
to these correlations it's a sequence of
semi-definite programs of increasing
size that gives you values that are
upper bounds on on this here okay so
this is known it's known that there's
always an algorithm that approaches this
value from below and an algorithm that
approaches this value from above
so now if the two values are equal and
you have an algorithm that approaches
from below an algorithm from their
approaches from above then the problem
of deciding or approximating this value
is is decidable you have two algorithms
that converge to the same thing but i
just showed that there must exist some
linear functions that comes from these
interactive roofs
for which computing the optimum is
undecidable
this one this is the one that that's
associated with the classes so computing
this value is undecidable so these two
algorithms cannot match and one of them
goes to the blue optimum the other the
purple optimum so these two optimal must
be different
and so this this difference is shown uh
follows from the
uh the undecidability user
okay so let me uh let me just wrap up um
so sorry i told you about this uh this
equality
um
and one of the things that i find
interesting about it is is all the
different uh strands uh or threads of
research that it builds on there's all
this work that happened in um
in complexity theory it was completely
unrelated and then we're connecting that
to
um insights from quantum information
in order to obtain uh surprising
resultant complexity theory that has
applications to to you know areas that
were disconnected from it since since
the 1930s sort of
there's many open questions i don't want
to to to say too much one of them is
just to circle back on this this notion
of a group being not hypo linear
not so fake is a related notion in case
someone knows about it
these are questions that group theorists
care a lot about they've been open for a
very very long time it would be nice if
every group was hyperlinear i think the
intuition is that it shouldn't be the
case because groups are just very
diverse
but this is still open because the
conjecture that every group is
hyperliner is a bit stronger
than con's embedding problems so this is
an open conjecture there's there's
actually a pretty clear path to showing
this based on refining the complexity
work that we did um it's a clear path
but it's not an easy path so so i just i
don't know about this uh a question that
i'm particularly interested in is if we
can use any of the work that was been
done there to make progress on a
conjecture in quantum complexity theory
that's that's been uh open for for a
while it was discussed at the program in
2014 already but there's not that much
work on it which is a quantum analog of
the pcp conjecture
um that's a question that the
mathematicians care about they see this
proof and it involves undecidability and
it just doesn't make sense that this
would be needed so you know someone has
to simplify it and there's many
technical questions but these maybe i'll
just reserve for the coffee break if
anyone is interested
so let me stop here
[Applause]
hey thomas great talk and great result
of course i still find it unbelievable
so so you you should so there's a proof
system that in a phenomenal time can
show that the program terminates in a
sense that's scenario so the question is
uh
so the helping problem is inari so the
question is is there some extended
notion of proof system for which one
could also prove infinite amount time
that the program does not terminate the
complement of the halting problem yeah
that's a good question it's not known
yet but um there's i think it's not
known yet uh but there's reasons to
think so
i regret now that i wasn't fully precise
so i developed a model of quantum
interactive proofs
um you know and the strategies are
quantum i didn't actually tell you what
of my two mathematical models was used
to define the complexity class
so i didn't say it but it's the blue
version the tensor product version
that's the version that's been accepted
you can ask what complexity class do you
get if you take the purple model so now
you have
now we know that it's a broader class of
strategies
and
that class is included in core re
um so it would be natural to show that
the complement of the halting problem is
is complete for it and it's it's not
known um um
but it's likely to be to be the case um
so if you just change the mathematical
model for your quantum correlations you
might you might go from re to re and go
back
so so just to be clear even though
this class
where you allow all commuting uh
operators is a border you're saying the
corresponding interactive proofs is not
is just incomparable it's not uh it's
not bigger yeah so that's the same thing
that could have happened between mip and
mip star it ended up you know just
because you allow more strategies they
can become incomparable so for mip store
it became it became bigger so they are
comparable it is bigger but there it
seems that that they are going to be
incomparable um yeah even though right
yeah
so uh i had a question
the
two models uh for quantum uh
uh which of them is considered to be
physical and which is not well that's a
great question ask a physicist um
i we don't know um you know physics etc
um
i mean one of them is broader than the
other so
the the more restricted one is you know
almost truly physical like all these
experiments that i described they verify
points in the more restricted set
so you could say well does physics allow
the broader set you know because i
mathematicians allow it but that's
physics and if you look at the
most general uh
versions of quantum mechanics so quantum
field theory relativistic quantum field
theory and you look at the most
permissive axioms for quant well for
quantum field theory
in principle it allows it so in
principle there is an experiment in
quantum field theory that would show
that would demonstrate a point that's in
the purple but not in the blue side
it's in principle because to do an
experiment you need a little bit more
than just say these are the axioms you
need an actual
theory
and in practice all the theories that
people manage to get their hands on they
are such that for these theories they
make extra assumptions and the two
models coincide
so you know it's not clear there could
be a physical experiment that separates
them but in principle in most permissive
models there could be
hi so i have a question so you know mip
starts equal re do you think there is
some limited notion of quantum
you know as well at some limited like
quantum communication between the
parties will be somehow between re and
nx
yeah
uh so that that part is not completely
nailed down but um
so okay just to make it precise what the
result says is that just in the context
of the halting problem is if you take a
turing machine and that turing machine
halts in a certain amount of time okay
but you don't know
there is a proof system
such that the provers are going to
succeed with red one in that proof
system as soon as the turing machine
huds now what amount of resources is
needed for them in order to convince you
the deterring machine helps that amount
of resources scales with the time the
deterring machine
takes to halt so in particular the
amount of entanglement they require is
going to scale polynomially with the
runtime of the chain machine the turing
machine doesn't hold there's no finite
amount of entanglement that's going to
be okay for them that's going to allow
them to succeed and that's the soundness
of our proof system so it's fine if the
turing machine doesn't halt it does halt
sorry in some amount of time they're
going to need that amount of environment
so now if you cap the amount of
entanglement that they're able to use
they become unable to convince you of
the fact that the turing machine helps
if it just takes too long to hud so you
could study a related class where the
amount of entanglement is like e you
know eq bits of entanglement and say
what's the
the time complexity class that you're
able to verify there and i think there's
an exponential gap between the upper
bound that you can show and the lower
bound but there's going to be a whole
hierarchy of such things and if you
allow more entanglement you'll get nx
and double e x and triple e and um
hi um so i was wondering um like what
you think about like how this complexity
theoretic result could actually maybe um
motivate us to try to understand like
which of the two
um sets is kind of like the right one
for quantum mechanics because it seemed
like since you showed that there's a
separation now there's kind of this
question of like
um which set is the right one um and
um i was wondering if there are
instances in physics where
like it actually matters because you
said like most of the theories the two
sets actually coincide um
yeah so it's kind of unfortunate that
both of them involve undecidable
problems right because you could have
had some very strong intuition
that you can't embed undecidable
problems in physical systems
um and or some related intuition maybe
might have much you know motivated you
to say this is not physical because it's
just it's um okay or do you want to say
no
so um so sorry but um but but this this
this separation is is when you have
approver right
so so if you if you sort of take away
the prover and you say well are these
two theories equivalent or not that's a
separate question and that's the answer
there
yeah yeah okay so maybe an important
clarification point is it it's not like
uh yeah which is sorry it's not like the
result doesn't say that uh there's
there's physical processes that solve
undecidable problems right right not at
all uh in order to succeed in the proof
system the provers have to know the
answer of the halting problem and we're
not saying how they figured that out
right i'm just they're just
they're just giving it to it and that
that's a purely just hypothetical
situation um
uh
okay so so so that's true
um okay so i guess you're saying that uh
the result by itself doesn't have an
implication for
what's physically realizable or not i
think that's fair uh yeah
all right
yeah um
i think can you mike
otherwise i don't care
yeah um i guess my main question was um
like
what does this result or like how could
this result um maybe help
uh us understand like what
like what mathematical um
like what mathematics we should be using
for for quantum mechanics yeah uh i mean
i think the short answer is that it
doesn't really you know it just it just
says that there's there's two there's a
difference between the two models but um
i don't think it gives a strong
indication one way or the other um
at least i don't see it
and then as i i guess uh in my answer to
to prasad um
you know in in practice and with a very
very lenient sense of practice it
actually doesn't make a difference right
because any kind of physical
physical even not not system like theory
that you can theoretically as a
physicist put your hands on and do any
kind of calculation the two sets are
going to be equal um so it's it it's
really if you're doing foundations work
that it might make a difference and
there i don't know you know i don't know
okay
so i'm wondering actually if you step
down from ari all the way down to earth
and you know you have actually something
that's uh i don't know even in p okay
how short can these because essentially
you can you know recursively make the
verifier more and more and more
efficient
so how succinctly these yeah i mean so
polynomial in the description size of
the turing machine um so constant
is this mean depends on your turing
machine yeah so if i had like a
concentrating machine doing a really
really you know difficult computation i
mean if you only talk about constant
things then you have to ask what's the
constant pre-factor and i don't know
what you know because constants always
but uh
yeah and in principle yes i mean i think
this is a potentially interesting
question like i don't have an
application for it like if i saw a way
to
um that an answer to that question might
help towards quantum pcb theorem or
these kinds of things that i would study
is more but the question is a little bit
doing when mip equals nx was shown and
then you asked that question you said
okay well we don't care about nx we want
point another size things and how can we
you know bring it back down and we care
about the proof line and we start
constructing pcps et cetera and you're
kind of asking there what kind of
objects would you would you get if you
just said what i'm interested in is a
real-time computation that's what i want
to delegate and then what's my effort
um yeah so
i think it's a good question i know
it can be worked out but
okay thank you thomas for taking us
through a wonderful journey through
physics math and computer science
[Applause]
so we can